hey I'm Lana Condor and I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm gonna be answering fan
questions while I play with can't stop
it how are you supposed to answer
questions like this oh my gosh okay I
guess we're gonna answer some questions
do you want to pick what advice you
think large gene would give to saya and
vice-versa Lara Jean would give the
advice to saya to be less aggressive to
chill out and just like write it write a
try letter
you don't cut you don't gotta go around
like swinging swords you can write a
letter and I think saya would tell
Largey to stand up for herself more do
you feel like you're more like saya from
deadly class or Lara from to all the
boys I definitely feel like I'm more
like Lara Jean from toddler boys I've
loved before because for a major reason
I don't kill people and also because
that I don't know I think my Regina's so
she's she's sweet and she's friendly and
sighs not very friendly
what's a role you auditioned for that
you didn't get but really wanted I just
refer Star Wars I didn't get that you
know what I really really wanted there's
a show called runaways and I really
really wanted it very badly
and I was so close and then I didn't get
it and then I ended up getting tell the
boys instead which I am very very happy
about it's super early on but what can
you tease about the tell the boys sequel
what are you most excited for well I'm
really excited there's gonna be a new
love interest along with Peter Kavinsky
there's gonna be a new love interest
John Ambrose which is gonna be epic so
I'm really excited about that because I
really can't wait to see the drama
between the two boys get spot over I
will love that so I can't wait for that
and I can't wait to see my sisters again
and Ana I'm very very excited to see
them
who is your dream actress to work with
and why Emily Blunt is my dream actress
to work with and I actually was super
close to her at the Golden Globes this
weekend but of course I I'm not
confident enough yet to meet her but I
will someday someday I'll go up and say
hi I love her so much
she's amazing if she sees I love that
she's such a family person as well and
she makes time for her family and what's
really important hi yes hello you know
you can't drop buzz feet how does it
feel to have seen such little Asian
representation on screen when you were
younger to now becoming one of the of
the people who's been an inspiration to
the Asian community I was so much
already now combined with these dogs and
that question made me emotional I think
growing up I didn't see I didn't see
myself represented that much on screen
almost to the point where I didn't even
know that that was something I was
missing for my life and so I decided
like I want that's all I wanted to do I
wanted to show younger girls someone
that looks like themselves on camera so
that they believe they can do it to [ __ ]
the industry is hard enough and there's
been so many young girls who've actually
come up to me since Lara Jean from sends
to all the boys and in a deadly class
that have been really emotional and
really excited to see someone that looks
like them and they feel seen and heard
and it's really an amazing and magical
experience
these boots are designer but you are the
only person who can ruin them and I
won't even be mad just get it just get
it what's your favorite movie of all
time Devil Wears Prada that was probably
my favorite movie was she goes she goes
and I love that and I did that to my
parents after watching Devil Wears Prada
like I don't know when I was like 13
12 or 13 or whatever after that I would
only go that's all to my parents they
were like this girl when Noah was here
he did an impression of you what's your
best impression of Noah
well obviously the who obviously that
but also Keith goes like this like a lot
like she's like so like like bro II and
my broad so it'll be like alright you
were mean he's out a lot but the little
rule is definitely my best thing who is
your celebrity crush growing up that's
easy
Zac Efron was my crush Zac I was the
perfect age for high school I was the
demographic bet on it bet on it bet on
it bet on me I was like yes I feel that
inks no I've never met Zac Efron and
I've you I don't think I can I don't
think I can I don't think my life will
be the same after I meet him so I think
it's probably for the best and I I don't
think I'll be able I'll make it
I think I'll I'll throw myself to the
ground and die after that you want to
read this for me what was it like
working with Janel Parrish do you ever
watch Pretty Little Liars working with
Janel Parrish was amazing because she
played my older sister but I felt like
she was my older sister in real life and
of course I watched Pretty Little Liars
and I'm such a big fan and she's I just
genuinely like the most amazing person
and she she provided so much advice for
me and help because she's been doing
this way longer than me um so she's just
been amazing and she I feel like I could
talk to her about anything what inspired
you to take the role of Laura Jean her
good heart that's what inspired me I
heard good hi you know what I bet you
have a good heart if you would know ever
to remake an iconic rom-com together
which one would it be and why I guess
maybe like Bridget Jones's Diary that
would be really fun or Devil Wears Prada
that's like a ish a rom-com do you think
large in whatever
get her scrunchie back uh-huh I don't
know I don't think so
also I don't thinks large and wants her
scrunchie back because I think by
Arjuna's a smart woman and she knows
don't share hair products and now with
Genevieve you'll know what she has her
hair so I don't think she wants it back
um but it's funny because ever since I
did a movie a lot of people will send me
scrunchies let's do one more one two one
more yes we do we want to do one more
who is your favorite Disney Princess
Mulan of course I'll make a man of you
Mulan Mu Shu not princess but in the
family all these puppies are available
for adoption through North Shore Animal
League America there's a cutest ever
thank you so much this has been so much
fun best interview of my life make sure
to watch deadly class on sci-fi January
16th it's going to be epic
[Music]